Greg here right now to give you a
special announcement in case you didn't
already catch the memo if you live in
the Los Angeles area or just visiting
Sunday February 19th John campia
Christian harloff and I are doing a live
show at Flappers that's in Burbank
California tickets have been selling
they've been selling fast thank you
everyone who's already bought a ticket
it's going to be a fun night there's
gonna be some stand-up comedy going on
before we go up there ourselves
Christian harloff is going to do some
comedy apparently he's funny or
something like that I've heard he's all
right John campia who knows what he'll
talk about maybe he'll rant about Bob
chapek Ezra Miller Robert Pattinson's
workout routine I gotta talk about Toby
McGuire's dick with him at some point
but yeah it's gonna be a good time and
hopefully to see you there of course
love to talk with everyone after the
show too tickets have been selling fast
so yep that's that's the end of this
announcement right now